let's kick this list off with lgd's
midlaner
maybe who's 2017 included a first-place
finish at Mars dota 2 league 2017 and
3rd and 4th place finishes at the summit
7 and the International 7 respectively a
veteran of the Chinese scene maybe was a
consistent force on LGD throughout 2017
as one of the more experienced players
on his roster
maybe's a great hero pool and strong
play played a big factor in their run at
TI it was a tough year for China by the
region's high standards but players like
maybe always show up and perform in 2017
was no exception number 9 on our list
resolution 1 is l1 Genting with digital
chaos he placed second at DAC with them
before posting a disappointing 9th to
16th finish at the kiev major as a
member of Thunderbird he then played
with team Empire at ti before joining og
where he plays 5th to 6th at dota pit
and won MDL Macau there's no question
that it's been a tumultuous year for the
young position to player as he's bounced
between three rosters it's the start of
the year and after a series of
organization transfers for the former DC
roster resolution wound up playing for
Team Empire at TI where he moved from
position 1 back to 2 and put on a show
in the process finally bring him down
after a breakout performance at TI
reaffirmed resolution as an
up-and-coming star he signed with og
that roster has not quite gelled in the
post TI season but shows a lot of
promise and is setting the stage for
2018 to be resolutions year you think
the boys can still I think of the
control council trying to run himself
away he's revving up the Requiem and ice
now goes back in I'll take the ultra
kill rampage Reza he wants it
home page get always you get a double
he's not done he walks for I'll take
that as well thank you very much what's
the diagram page for Reza coming in at
number eight is a foo who placed 3rd to
4th at epicenter second at MDL third at
the international and third at perfect
world masters a foo made a name for
himself in the later parts of 2016 with
Warriors gaming unity but the Malaysian
players big streak came when he signed
on LGD foreveryoung
alongside what looked like one of the
strongest teams in China lfy made a run
to third at TI seven after a group stage
where they looked like one of the
strongest teams in the tournaments ha
micro guy then of course a few managed
to pull off one of the most impressive
plays of the tournaments a well rounded
position for player with great ganking
and play making a foo was a standout
player in a year where China as a region
struggled overall empowered by changes
to the game that gave position for
players more access to gold a foo was
part of a wave of support of players
that changed what was expected of their
role
bracket final number 7 on our list mid-1
had a rocky start to the year
placing 9th to 16th at the kiev major
and 9th 12th at the international but
with a rejuvenated team secret in the
post TI season mid wine and company put
up strong results placing 2nd at ESL one
Hamburg and winning dreamleague season 8
a powerful position to player mid one
has been part of a shift in the role
that has seen more hard carry physical
damage heroes like phantom Lancer and
ember spirits when secrets struggled at
the beginning of the year mid wine was
the team's primary carry and now with
ace taking some of that burden off his
shoulders he looks just as strong get
the double kill the tiger gets too much
he's still full health upon triple kill
for gh we'll buy back the absolutes got
the vision on to mind-control that claim
themselves that fall though it is still
extremely early in the new season team
secret looked like the squad to beat
right now and mid one is a big reason
why this rapier doing so much work in
this teamfight no one who comes in at
number 6 on our list was part of a
surging virtus Pro roster that surprised
everyone with the results that they
posted in 2017 including a second-place
finish at the kiev major a 5th to 6th
finish at the international and a
first-place finish at ESL one Hamburg
no one's 2017 may not be remembered in
the same way as some of DotA's other
superstars but the CIS squads
consistently high placings have put them
in the conversation among some of the
world's top teams
to run away no one's excellent laning
deep hero pool and ability to completely
dominate certain games make him one of
the year's biggest breakup players and
of course he also did this no one
delivers big on that
number five on our list jer axe placed
second at DAC 2017 and won the kiev
major but after a 7th to 8th finish at
TI 7 o G have struggled to put up the
same results in the latter half of the
year and the new dota season with the gr
axe on the team
Oh G won back-to-back majors at the end
of 2016 at the beginning of 2017 at the
beginning of the year they look to be
one of the best teams in the world
Paul Jackson HN does it again and Jer
axes position for support play was the
bedrock on which oh geez period of
dominance was built upon his solid play
on picks like treant protector at the
kiev major set the bar for how good a
position for could look this year
jackson OG haven't been able to maintain
this position at the top of the dollar
world and they're still looking to find
consistent success post TI but to say
that this roster has a lot of potential
for 2018 would be an understatement
number 4 on our list miracle placed 5th
to 8th at the kiev major n1 epicenter
2017 but of course his biggest
accomplishment is the world title he won
at the international 7 after TI miracle
and Team Liquid placed 3rd to 4th at ESL
one Hamburg and second at dream league
season 8 one of the most gifted dota
talents in the world
the young prodigy has tasted success
before but his win at the international
cemented his place in dota history most
of the players paid off them because
they went out they want to do something
later I want to play dota because I
wanted even TI he wants to in TI
but he just wants the eye without
thinking about winning TI he plays dota
because he wants to have fun miracles
greatest strength is his enormous hero
pool
he played 22 heroes during TI 7 and his
incredible performances on a huge range
of heroes throughout the year has been
at the heart of liquid success miracle
is a player who demands a team built
around him and liquid have done exactly
that to an enormous amount of success
[Applause]
coming in at number three is SCCC who
placed 9th to 16th at the kiev major and
second at ti7
after the international newbie place in
the top four at ESL one Hamburg won the
perfect world masters minor and placed
5th to 6th at dreamleague season 8
it wasn't an especially strong year for
China and dota 2
but newbie were the exception despite
their struggles in the early portion of
2017
newbies run at TI 7 earned them and
especially SCCC the admiration of fans
know anything is ships in the night eg
is checking everywhere where some
players have taken physical damage
carries to the midlane SCCC
excelled on mage pics like storm spirit
and invoker allowing mugie to play
scaling position one picks though SCCC
demands a lot of resources in draft and
an in-game his play more than makes up
for it and he was a huge part of new be
successful 2017 oh yes man he that's a
great amber today this game there's to
be no exception number 2 on our list is
gh who like miracle played on Team
Liquid throughout 2017 and was
instrumental in their win at the
international 7 playing in his first
major tournament with Team Liquid in
late 2016 gh is a first full calendar
year playing dota 2 professionally has
been one for the history books as he
exploded onto the scene with a versatile
hero pool and an impactful set of
signature picks the scariest thing about
gh is the amount of pressure he puts on
your team during a draft his play on
picks like earth shaker IO and
/ of the light drew bands throughout the
year but he's been able to consistently
perform
despite being targeted gh is one of the
most successful rookies in the history
of dota and he already has a TI title
under his belts to say the future is
bright for this player is an
understatement number one on our list
couldn't be anyone other than team
liquids captain kuroky he was the
mastermind behind team liquids
incredible 2017 and it was his
leadership that helped his team lift the
aegis of champions
kuroky had been determined to return to
the TI finals since he made it there
with Navi back in 2013 he helped Billy
Team liquids 2017 roster with the hopes
of doing just that and his focus and
leadership were a huge factor in their
championship win kuroky is one of the
game's most consistent and knowledgeable
position v supports and he always seems
to find himself in the right place to
enable his team but it's probably true
that winning ti7
meant more to kuroky than anyone else on
his team and his emotional reaction to
their 3o sweep we'll stick with us
[Applause]
20:17 was the year that kuroky finally
led his team to the biggest prize in
eSports but with the team sticking it
together after the tournaments we can't
wait to see what Team Liquid managed to
do in 2018
[Applause]
you